and then now you can see we can go
around and edit the numbers on a web
page edit anything basically so i
highlighted the nine i'm going to type a
two here
and instead of minutes i'm going to
change it to seconds
and instead of 1000 subscribers maybe i
want 1.3 million subscribers i don't
know
[Music]
[Applause]
alright welcome to my first video
um
bought a new laptop and
[Music]
[Music]
thanks for watching thanks for watching
thanks for watching this video thanks
for rating and thanks for subscribing
talk to you guys later
peace
so thank you
just wanted to say thanks this is the
first video i'm uploading to over 10
million subscribers on youtube
and i just wanted to give a shout out to
every one of you that's been here for
days weeks months thank you for watching
big shout out to any creators that i've
collaborated with over the past 10 years
and a hundred and a thousand plus videos
uh big shout out to any musicians and
artists that i've worked with on videos
big shout out to tech companies making
these incredible products that we get to
share i feel like the best part of my
job
is getting to share this passion i've
had from as long as i can remember
with all of you guys and it's incredible
seeing so many people also share that
passion 2020 is right around the corner
and i'm super excited to start another
fresh brand new decade with all of you
guys and i feel like this is a pretty
great foundation to be getting it all
with so
thanks again thanks for watching thanks
for subscribing
catch you guys in the next one
peace